a calls for a warm milk full of coffee
and bagels I like the sound of that
Rocky is alive in downtown Summerlin
showing us how to celebrate National
Bagel day on overload this Sunday hi
Rocky
you guys I am on I am on overload
actually because this just came out the
oven and it is delicious Jordan isn't it
really good it is delicious if you've
ever had a hot fresh Bagel Right Out the
Oven you're missing out so do that here
at the bagel Nook this weekend Sunday
National Bagel day but besides the you
know the regular classic Bagels they
have overload Bagels that is a Flamin
Hot Cheeto Bagel Doritos Cinnamon Toast
Crunch and that's what you guys do here
at the bagel now keeping it unique um
and it's become a destination how so uh
people have seen us on Tick Tock social
media and they've come from all across
you know the states to come see what we
have to offer okay now you guys are
seeing it right now so come over here
we're going to show you what we're
talking about we've got all of this is
shmear okay explain what kind of flavors
you guys have we have 45 different
flavor uh cream cheeses from uh
blueberry crumb to Blazing Ranch to
Plate bacon shatter cold Ranch Nutella
peanut butter Fruity Pebbles cannoli
birthday cake everything seed and all I
heard was Fruity Pebbles because now I'm
ready to talk about the overload the
overload Bagel here the Fruity Pebbles
flavor that's what you're going to show
me yeah there's tomato right now for you
we've got hot Cheetos Bagel as well oh
my gosh how much fun do you have making
these
a lot
it's fun to learn all the different
recipes and like mess around with it
what's the craziest one you made so far
[Music]
probably the Elvis it's
um a french toast bagel with the peanut
butter swirl cream cheese with bacon and
bananas inside oh my gosh wow that is
wild that's decadent and besides all of
that you guys look at the menu up there
you have actually Savory you know
sandwiches and different kinds of you
got quesadillas on the menu explain that
everything we have something for
everybody and uh it's very unique and
it's also very New Jersey things that
you had on the East Coast like right now
you can see an avocado blast we made
over here oh yeah you want to see that
real quick avocado blast oh my gosh I
love that it's got a hash brown on there
yes so it's hash browns uh avocado
lettuce tomato cheese and then we just
close it up and insert it to people yeah
something for everybody here and now
we're going to take you back to the
Fruity Pebbles Bagel because we've got
about 30 seconds left for me to taste
this okay you guys I'm gonna give you
the mic invite everybody down to Bagel
National Bagel Day on Sunday please come
we would love to welcome you if you've
cared for the first time to try what we
have to offer and I hope you enjoy the
overload
wow is it really good now is it all over
my face no you look amazing this is so
good you guys have to bring the whole
family down to the bagel nug here in
downtown Summerlin and we will be right
back wow that was good girl